.
* Pulsierende Klavier-
und Schlagzeugklänge *
Franziska Quadri ist Tetraplegikerin.
Seit einem Gleitschirmunfall
vor zehn Jahren
ist sie vom Hals an abwärts gelähmt,
kann weder Arme noch Beine bewegen.
Klar kann ich sehr vieles
nicht mehr.
Es gibt sicher auch Menschen,
die so nicht mehr leben wollen.
Ich dachte ja früher auch so.
Aber man wächst in das Ganze hinein.
Und wenn man wieder geflickt ist,
kann man nicht sagen:
"Jetzt will ich nicht mehr leben."
- Haben Sie sich das manchmal gesagt?
Am Anfang
war dieses Thema sehr präsent,
auch als ich realisierte, dass
die Schmerzen immer stärker werden.
Und einfach die ganze Hilflosigkeit,
die ganze Abhängigkeit.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
damit umzugehen.
Deshalb waren diese Gedanken da.
Aber ich wusste auch, dass ich
aktiv etwas unternehmen müsste,
um meinem Leben ein Ende zu setzen.
Dazu war ich nicht in der Lage.
Und ich glaube, ich werde auch nie
in der Lage dazu sein.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Ächzen *
Meine erste Begegnung mit Franziska
Quadri fand im Jahr 2016 statt -
in ihrer Wohnung in Zürich.
* Ächzen *
Willst du mich kurz rüber... Zieh
mich besser auf der anderen Seite.
Ja.
Es war auch eine erste Begegnung
mit den unvorstellbaren Schmerzen
in ihren gelähmten Gliedern.
Schnell.
Nimm die Hüfte und Knie zuerst.
Okay,
dann kannst du mich gleich drehen.
* Schmerzerfülltes Stöhnen *
Zieh mich noch etwas nach hinten
an den Hüften.- Mhm.
Du kannst mich ein ziemliches Stück
nach hinten nehmen.
* Ächzen *
Weisst du was, versuch es mal ...
Ich glaube, du kannst sie
gar nicht beugen, sie sind so steif.
Ja, so ist super.
Was waren das für Zuckungen?
Das sind Spastiken,
eigentlich Fehlinformationen.
Mein Hirn kann die Berührungen
nicht wirklich verarbeiten.
Dann reagiert mein Körper
mit solchen Krämpfen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
extrem schmerzhaft.
Ja, das ist sehr schmerzhaft,
v.a. in Kombination
mit den neuropathischen Schmerzen,
die ich habe.
Das ist ziemlich ...
Oh, du hast gleich alles zugedeckt.
- Ja.
In Kombination
mit den neuropathischen Schmerzen
ist es wirklich sehr schlimm.
* Treibende Klaviermusik *
Seit diesen Aufnahmen
sind knapp vier Jahre vergangen.
Nun hat sich Franzsika Quadri
wieder gemeldet.
Es gehe ihr heute
viel besser als damals.
Grund genug, sie erneut zu besuchen.
Wie von Geisterhand
öffnet sich die Tür ihrer Wohnung.
Franziska Quadri kann den Mechanismus
von ihrem Bett aus
mit dem Mund bedienen.
Denn dort liegt sie
noch immer regungslos.
Noch im Bett raucht Franziska Quadri
ihren ersten Joint
gegen den Schmerz und die Spastik.
Die berauschende Wirkung des Cannabis
spürt sie schon längst nicht mehr.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
es gehe Ihnen viel besser.
In welcher Beziehung denn?
Eigentlich in jeder Beziehung,
psychisch und auch körperlich.
Man sieht nicht direkt,
dass ich viel mehr bewegen kann,
aber ich bin viel stabiler,
werde nicht mehr so schnell krank.
Ich erbreche nicht mehr ständig
nach dem Essen,
habe ziemlich an Gewicht zugelegt.
Alles in allem geht es mir viel
besser als noch vor drei Jahren.
Worauf ist das zurückzuführen?
Auf meine Disziplin
und meine unermüdliche Suche danach,
dass es mir besser geht.
Ich habe auch
fast alle Medikamente abgesetzt,
weil ich gemerkt habe,
dass sie mir nicht guttun
und dass ich nicht über Jahre
so viele Schmerzmittel
einnehmen kann.
Das habe ich durch Cannabis ersetzt.
Ich mache sehr viel in Eigenregie.
Es geht Franziska Quadri besser.
Doch die Schmerzen
sind noch immer da ...
Warte kurz.
- ... unvermindert.
Ja, jetzt ist gut.
Am Anfang versuchte ich,
nicht an den Schmerz zu denken,
ihn auszublenden.
Jetzt habe ich gelernt,
mit ihm zu leben.
Er ist wie ein Kollege oder Freund,
sicher nicht mein bester,
aber er gehört irgendwie dazu.
Wenn ich versuche,
ihn auszuschliessen, wehrt er sich.
(Flüsternd) Okay.
Vor ihrem Unfall arbeitete
Franziska Quadri in einem Werbebüro.
Sie hatte eine Beziehung,
reiste viel,
machte Sport und ging auf Partys.
Heute
dominiert der Schmerz ihr Leben.
Gelähmt zu sein heisst noch
lange nicht, dass man nichts spürt.
Bei mir ist es so,
dass ich gar nichts bewegen kann,
ich aber meinen ganzen Körper spüre.
Was ich spüre, ist aber nur Schmerz.
Aber trotz allem
möchte ich nicht darauf verzichten,
denn ich finde es schön,
zu wissen, wo meine Füsse sind
oder genaue Anweisungen geben zu
können, wie man mich hinsetzen soll.
Wenn der Arm so hinunterhängt,
merken Sie, dass er einfach hängt?
Ich weiss genau, wo er ist.
Das ist mein linker Arm, den
kann ich etwas bewegen, wenn er ...
Aber mehr geht nicht.
Franziska Quadri ist 44 Jahre alt
und lebt in einer Mietwohnung
in Zürich Wipkingen.
Ein Leben im Pflegeheim
war für sie nie eine Option.
Sie beschäftigt
zwei Pflegefachfrauen,
die jeweils zwei Monate am Stück
Tag und Nacht bei ihr leben.
Ihr Kampf für ein selbstbestimmtes
Leben mit Assistenzbeiträgen
hat sie
bis vor Bundesgericht geführt.
Etwas nach oben.
Okay.
Kannst du mir diese Strähne noch ...
Sehr gut.
Es ist Ihnen wichtig,
dass Sie schön aussehen, oder?
Ähm ...
Das Thema ist etwas schwierig.
Eigentlich interessiert es mich
nicht mehr wirklich.
Ich kann nicht mehr selbst ...
Du kannst ihn wegnehmen, danke.
Ich kann nicht mehr selbst
in den Spiegel schauen.
Diese gelähmten Körperteile
wirken schon etwas ...
... ja, auch auf mich ...
Manchmal gehören sie
nicht so ganz zu meinem Körper,
gerade wenn sie so schmerzen.
Und halt auch die Haare
gehen kaputt, brechen,
weil ich immer am Rollstuhl anlehne.
Das sind schon so Dinge, Eitel-
keiten, die zum Vorschein kommen.
Aber ich versuche das zu verdrängen
und abzulegen.
Es gibt wichtigere Dinge
auf dieser Welt.- Z.B.?
Dass man zufrieden ist und ...
- Sind Sie zufrieden?
Ja, ich würde sagen,
ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Ich habe nicht nur Dinge verloren.
Ich bin zwar
nicht mehr selbstständig,
aber ich habe auch Dinge gewonnen.
Denn ich kann heute machen,
was ich will.
Ich kann mir den Tag so einteilen,
wie ich das möchte.
Ich kann meine Energie für Dinge
brauchen, die mir wichtig sind,
bei denen ich
mit dem Herzen dabei bin.
Das bringt eine Zufriedenheit,
die viele heute nicht mehr haben.
Und ich habe all das.
* Pulsierende Klavier-
und Schlagzeugklänge *
Bring mal beide, dann schauen wir,
wie wir sie am besten platzieren,
damit es schön ist.
Einmal pro Woche
malt Franziska Quadri,
unterstützt
von einer Kunsttherapeutin.
Dann entstehen solche Selbstporträts.
Was ist das für eine Franziska Quadri
auf diesem Bild?
Die ist ein bisschen
in sich gekehrt.
Seit dem Unfall
bin ich schon eher ruhig geworden.
Ich bin halt oft auch allein
und gehe etwas in mich.
Zeig mir mal den Pinsel.
Das ist doch wie ein Oval.
Jetzt würde ich einfach schauen,
dass wir die in die Mitte ...
Weisst du, wie ich meine,
wie wir die legen?
So, genau.
Was bedeutet Ihnen dieses Malen?
Es ist etwas vom Wichtigsten
für mich.
Zum einen ist es total schön,
dass ich meinen linken Arm
noch etwas brauchen kann,
also die wenigen Funktionen,
die ich noch habe.
Das andere ist, dass ich in den
Bildern meine ganzen Erfahrungen,
die ich in den letzten zehn Jahren
gemacht habe, verarbeiten kann.
Es ist eine Art,
um mich selbst zu therapieren.
* Treibende, glockige Klaviermusik *
Immer am Jahrestag ihres Unfalls
entsteht ein neues Selbstporträt.
Es geschah am 17. Mai 2009.
Beim Starten riss eine Windbö
Franziskas Gleitschirm
ein paar Meter in die Höhe.
Sie stolperte
und stürzte kopfüber in eine Wiese.
Beim Aufprall
brach ihre Halswirbelsäule.
Am Anfang weinte ich nur,
ich war nur todtraurig.
Dann entsteht daraus eine Wut.
Eine Wut gegen sich,
eine Wut gegen die anderen.
Irgendwann wird es zu Eifersucht:
Andere können noch, du nicht mehr.
Man geht wirklich
durch verschiedene Gefühlsebenen.
Heute ist es so, dass ich ...
Nein, ich glaube,
ich ärgere mich nicht mehr darüber.
Ich glaube, ich muss das
wirklich einfach hinter mir lassen
und annehmen, wie es ist,
sonst tue ich mir keinen Gefallen.
Zehn Jahrestage - zehn Selbstporträts
im Gedenken an ihren Unfall.
Mit den Jahren sind all ihre Bilder
freundlicher geworden.
Die eine Hälfte des Gesichts scheint
überdeckt. Was hat das zu bedeuten?
Das soll symbolisieren,
dass ich mich
schon nicht so verstanden fühle.
Die Leute schauen mich manchmal
verschreckt an,
wenn sie mich im Rollstuhl sehen.
Es ist einfach schwierig, zu merken,
dass man ein Aussenseiter ist.
Es ist mir schon bewusst, dass ich
durch den Elektrorollstuhl auffalle
und anders bin als die anderen.
Aber wenn die Leute
so verschreckt auf einen reagieren,
macht mich das schon etwas traurig.
* Pulsierende Klavier-
und Schlagzeugklänge *
Unverstanden
fühlt sich Franziska Quadri auch,
wenn es um Cannabis geht.
Für sie
ein unverzichtbares Heilmittel,
für die Gesellschaft eine Droge.
Aus diesem Grund engagiert sie sich
als Präsidentin für MedCan,
den Medical Cannabis Verein Schweiz.
Er setzt sich
für die Anliegen von Menschen ein,
die Cannabis medizinisch anwenden.
Ich glaube schon,
dass ich die treibende Kraft bin.
Es machen schon noch andere mit.
Ich setze all meine Fähigkeiten um,
die ich früher
als Grafikerin brauchte.
Ich schreibe viel,
das macht mir Spass,
und betreue die Webseite.
Bei allem, was ansteht,
bin ich an vorderster Front dabei.
* Piepen *
Hallo, Simon.
Wie findest du es, Fragezeichen.
Vielleicht
kann ich den Text auch weglassen ...
... und du schreibst ihn ...
... darunter.
* Pulsierende Gitarren-
und Schlagzeugklänge *
Du kommst mich extra abholen? Hoi!
Ich begrüsse euch herzlich
zum Patiententreffen.
Schön, dass ihr hier seid.
Heute ist die Runde etwas kleiner.
Aber bei diesem Herbstwetter können
viele wegen Schmerzen nicht kommen.
Als Präsidentin von MedCan
leitet Franziska Quadri auch
die monatlichen Patiententreffen
in Zürich.
Der Verein fordert Straffreiheit
für Patientinnen und Patienten.
Denn sie alle leben in ständiger
Angst vor dem Eingreifen der Behörde.
Ihre Forderung
an die aktuelle Revision
des Betäubungsmittelgesetzes:
der gemeinschaftlich organisierte
Cannabis-Eigenanbau.
Dieser sei im Moment
die einzige Möglichkeit,
zahlbare und hochstehende
Cannabis-Medikamente zu erhalten.
Es ist so, dass letztes Wochenende
Parlamentswahlen waren.
Diese Wahlen sind für uns
eigentlich gut herausgekommen.
Es sieht so aus, als wären
mehr Politiker im Parlament,
die Cannabis befürworten.
Ich dachte, wir schicken ihnen allen
unsere Medienbroschüre
und machen auf uns aufmerksam,
damit sie Bescheid wissen,
dass es uns gibt.
Als Franziska vor zig Jahren
zu uns kam,
hat sie uns total überrascht mit
der Power, die sie entwickelt hat.
Denn sie hat einen Ort gefunden,
an dem sie plötzlich gemerkt hat:
"Ich kann wieder etwas
zur Gesellschaft beitragen."
Vorher lag sie
relativ flach im Bett,
von allen Medikamenten betäubt.
Als Präsidentin ist sie Motor
und gleichzeitig
für viele andere Patienten
ein Riesenvorbild,
wie man sein Schicksal wieder
selbst in die Hand nehmen kann.
Einer, der sich Franziska Quadri
zum Vorbild genommen hat,
ist Simon Winistörfer, der mit 23
an Multipler Sklerose erkrankt ist.
Links bin ich in einem
sehr schlechten Krankheitsmoment.
Man sieht, dass ich extrem
aufgedunsen bin vom Cortison
und all den Medikamenten.
Und wenn Sie das Foto
heute anschauen?
Ich kann fast nicht glauben,
dass das erste Foto
nur 16 Monate
vor dem zweiten entstanden ist.
Und wie stark ich mich
verändert habe,
nachdem ich viele Medikamente
absetzen konnte.
Ich nehme natürlich immer noch
Therapien zur Behandlung der MS.
Aber all die Medikamente gegen die
Nebenwirkungen sind total ersetzt.
Ihre Medikamente
und die Cannabisblüten zum Rauchen
beschafft sich Franziska Quadri
illegal.
Denn die Cannabis-Tropfen,
die sie mit einer Ausnahmebewilligung
von ihrem Arzt erhält,
wirken viel zu schwach.
Ich habe mit dem Rollstuhl
natürlich schon das Glück,
dass es eher akzeptiert wird.
Ich mache mir wirklich
keine grossen Sorgen.
Ich versuche,
nicht so daran zu denken.
Aber Sie
würden sich das nicht trauen?
Wenn ich muss, konsumiere ich auch
in der Öffentlichkeit,
ich versuche mich aber
etwas zu verstecken.
Was merkt man?
Bei diesem Scheisswetter
haben alle wieder mehr Schmerzen.
Im Winter sind Franziskas Schmerzen
immer besonders heftig.
Darum flieht sie seit fünf Jahren
jeweils Ende Oktober nach Teneriffa.
Begleitet von ihren Eltern,
die sie bedingungslos unterstützen.
Wie viel Gras ist noch da, Mami?
Ja, vielleicht müsstest du ...
- Zeig mal.
Schon noch für ein paar Tage.
Ich bräuchte eben gleich noch mal.
- Vielleicht noch für eine Woche.
Nimm doch gleich noch mal, dann
müssen wir nicht noch mal gehen.
Das hätten Sie sich wohl
auch nie träumen lassen,
dass Sie einmal Joints füllen würden.
Joints füllen
für eine meiner Töchter, genau.
Obwohl ich ihnen immer sagte,
was für ein Teufelszeug das sei.
Aber, ja ...
Sie kann es nicht selbst.
Und dann machen wir das eben.
Ich selber
habe noch nie einen geraucht.
Aber vielleicht muss ich es
irgendwann doch noch probieren,
wer weiss.
In Spanien ist den Einheimischen
der Besitz von Cannabis
für den persönlichen Gebrauch
erlaubt.
Touristen wie die Quadris allerdings
bewegen sich
in einer rechtlichen Grauzone.
Here is the cannabis. Okay?
You can move to the office.
Ich sehe einfach die Wirkung des
Cannabis bei der eigenen Tochter.
Ich habe auch
einiges darüber gelesen.
Ich muss sagen: Warum nicht?
Für Leute, die es brauchen, für
medizinische oder sonstige Zwecke.
Aber sicher nicht, um sich
einen schönen Abend zu machen.
Nicht nur die Familie
unterstützt Franziska Quadri.
So kommt der Besuch.
Auch ihre Freunde
haben ihr nach dem Unfall
ausnahmslos die Treue gehalten.
Ciao zusammen.
- Ciao.
Ich habe heute beim Mittagessen an
dich gedacht. Ich war beim Asiaten.
Es hätte dir sicher auch geschmeckt,
aber es ist kacke zum Essen,
ich habe es mit Stäbchen versucht.
- Ja, wir wollten auch mal gehen.
Sie sind so glitschig.
- Mit der Nudelsuppe ja auch.
Ich habe trotzdem an dich gedacht
und an Kanada, ganz fest.- Super.
Aber Franziskas Unfall war auch
für ihr Umfeld eine Herausforderung.
Ich habe gemerkt,
wie gehemmt im Umgang ich bin,
wie ich z.B. versuche,
ja nichts Falsches zu sagen.
Oder ich habe Themen ausgeschlossen.
Eine Wanderung,
die ich gemacht habe,
oder ein körperliches Erlebnis,
habe ich versucht zu umgehen.
Aber ...
Es gehört auch dazu,
sonst ist es gekünstelt.
Und ich spüre, dass ich gehemmt bin.
Und ...
Es hat lange gebraucht, aber
unterdessen hat sich alles gelegt.
(Alle) Zum Wohl, cheers.
Gib mir das kleine,
das mit weniger drin.
Inzwischen ist ihre
zweite Assistentin aus der Slowakei
wieder bei Franziska Quadri
eingezogen
und kocht für sie
und ihre langjährigen Freunde.
In ihrer Wohnung gehe es manchmal zu
wie in einem Bienenhaus,
sagt Franziska Quadri.
Und sie mittendrin.
Ich bin sonst schon
eher ein Optimist.
Aber Franzi so leben zu sehen,
das ist für mich so stärkend.
Man tut alles, was man nur kann,
für sie, damit es ihr gut geht.
Und das gibt sie auch
ständig zurück.
Klar wussten wir am Anfang nicht,
wie wir uns verhalten sollten,
aber das Wichtige war,
Zeit zusammen zu verbringen
und es gegenseitig zu lernen.
* Husten *
Auch wenn sie
einen grossen Freundeskreis
und eine unterstützende Familie hat -
Franziska Quadri
fühlt sich oft einsam
und sehnt sich nach einer Beziehung.
Ansonsten aber
lebe sie ein gutes Leben.
Gut so?
- Ja, so ist gut.
Ich glaube, das Happy End ist ...
... eigentlich
schon fast geschrieben.
Ich habe
in den letzten zehn Jahren gelernt,
mit dieser schwierigen Situation
und dem Rollstuhl umzugehen
und mir ein neues Leben aufzubauen,
neue Aufgaben zu finden.
Ich finde,
das habe ich sehr gut geschafft.
Ich führe jetzt wieder
ein zufriedenes Leben.
Und ich finde,
das ist eigentlich ...
... vielleicht kein Happy End,
bei dem man am Schluss
in den Sonnenuntergang reitet,
aber das würde auch gar nicht so
zu mir passen.
Ich glaube, das Happy End
meines Films wird sein,
dass ich
trotz meiner schwierigen Situation
ein schönes Leben geführt habe,
ein zufriedenes Leben,
viele Freunde hatte.
Und ich hoffe,
noch einiges bewegen zu können.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2020